[Music]
this is the roux this is just a little
bit of butter that we melt and then I
add a touch of flour to it and as it
thickens up we had a little bit of cream
to it I don't know how much magic we got
going on right here let me ask you
quickly I know that this is a pasta
recipe and you you want you have
something called a stalker pasta that
you make how did it get the word do the
name stalker pasta okay I'm gonna leave
the actor's name out of it be to protect
them but I made a dish on a movie a long
time ago and the sauce was so good I'm
blaming the sauce was so good that this
person really had a crush on me and
would literally when I moved they would
move and I moved to get moved with you
and they moved again and when my wife
and I started dating there would be a
car on my street and we would have like
a good night smooth right like had a
nice night oh yeah me too all right
nights bold and they will go on and we
both freaked out and the car would zip
down and then park in the driveway where
they moved like I wouldn't know who that
was
now I can't say it wasn't might have
been a boy you don't know you don't know
hey I think everyone deserves their own
stalker so that's why put the recipe in
the book so enjoy all right do you guys
want to come over do you want to try any
of this it's gonna be amazing Andy Rosen
mash tuns all right so this is a roux
this is a roux and from that we're gonna
add four cheese's I'm gonna add Gruyere
fontina parmesan and you can use white
cheddar if you want we're gonna use an
orange cheddar and all that cheese is
gonna form our sauce okay this is
fantastic and mac and cheese is one of
those dishes that doesn't even have to
be that good you can have when I have
awful mac and cheese it's the best thing
I've had that day it's one of those
foods it has a very low baseline you're
making is much better than it has to be
no this is a basic sauce for almost
every sauce you've ever loved we're just
using it for mac and cheese and when
this is done we will set it aside we'll
get our noodles here after we boil them
and we're gonna do it in three little
layers we're gonna go noodles cheese
sauce noodles cheese sauce noodles
cheese sauce into the oven with some
bread crumbs on top and when we pull it
out it looks delicious and it's right
down here actually Oh thing we just cut
you when it saw what you doing down
there
I'm gonna give
[Applause]
that is fantastic
smelling you can't smell this through
the television but it smells doesn't
that smell fantastic what's in this yeah
let me smell though
oh yeah it's but no magic butter but
still oh it smells so good oh but it
could be better goodness welcome to
Southern California we have a fork we
can eat and if we don't I'm using my
hands okay here's your not skipped over
all that's wrong got kind of annihilated
throughout the process so I'm gonna
spare you the cheese and then it would
start to stink and not smell good
instead of we were trying to talk and
cook at the same time yeah pretty much
don't touch that with your dirty I don't
want them no no Eddie gave me a
disinfectant thing so now you're free to
love it alright let's work it up all
right there you go I'll be very good you
guys Gus first you mean just take the
fork can I spit in there all right I'll
go right in the middle oh my god that's
right there he goes
[Applause]